Alors voilà, moi c’est Pitcho.
Il m’a présenté.
Transcription: Federica Colombo
Relecteur: eric vautier
C’est très compliqué
de présenter quelqu’un.
Il m’a présenté par mon prénom ;
mon identité est l’identité de mon prénom.
Mon nom de famille, c'est Wamba Kanga.
Je suis congolais, mais pendant longtemps,
j'avoue, j'ai détesté la rumba congolaise.
Maintenant, ça va un peu mieux.
Je suis aussi belge,
mais je ne bois pas de bière.
Ça veut dire que, en fait,
je suis plusieurs.
Et je ne suis pas fou.
Même s'ils sont pleins dans ma tête.
Ils sont pleins dans ma tête.
Je les entends.
Ils sont, mais vraiment, plein, plein,
plein dans ma tête.
S’ils se bousculent, je les contiens,
Ils se sont plaints.
Ils se sont plaints
parce qu’on n’entend pas leur voix,
qu’on fait semblant de ne pas les voir.
Et pourtant, à chaque fois, à chaque fois
que je mets les voiles, ils me suivent.
Eh bien oui, c’est à moi, tout ça.
À moi tout seul, je suis un peuple.
Pour me raconter, il faudrait un péplum.
Parfois, souvent, je n’en peux plus.
Surtout quand ils parlent en même temps.
Comment ? Comment choisir ?
Je les aime tant.
Dois-je vraiment être dans un camp
pour me prétendre militant ?
Si c’est le cas, je suis un mutant
au croisement de plusieurs chemins.
J’avais des plans,
mais la vie avait d’autres schémas.
Je suis parti de chez moi pour découvrir
le monde et le monde est devenu chez moi.
Je me construis, me détruis, me réinvente,
entre nature morte et vivante,
au gré des gens, au gré du vent.
À chaque instant je me...
Je me...
Je me métamorphose.
Je suis tellement, tellement, tellement,
tellement, tellement de choses.
Leurs clichés sont tellement...
Mais oui, mais tellement,
tellement de mensonges.
Mais heureusement, heureusement que le
monde est constamment en mouvement.
C’est consternant ces gens qui s’évertuent
à vivre entre monuments et statues.
Les mots me manquent pour décrypter tous
ces boniments qui nous saturent l'esprit.
Mais c'est fini.
Ce n’est plus leurs yeux, mais uniquement
mon regard qui me définit.
Ce n’est plus leur Dieu
qui me juge ou me punit.
Je connais leur jeu du tiroir,
ils veulent m’y loger,
mais je suis un pur produit du terroir,
mélangé comme une recette
aux mille épices.
Je brouille les pistes.
Fier de l’être.
Une exception parmi les règles.
Un phénix parmi les aigles.
Mais quand je déploie mes ailes,
j'arrondis les angles.
Car la vérité demande
une vision à 360 degrés
à travers des nuages de nuances de gris.
Je me construis, me détruis, me réinvente,
entre nature morte et vivante,
au gré des gens, au gré du vent.
À chaque instant, je me métamorphose.
Je suis tellement, tellement,
tellement, tellement,
tellement, tellement de choses.
Leurs clichés sont tellement, tellement,
tellement, tellement, tellement
de mensonges.
Il y a tellement, tellement de questions.
Mais on s'en fout de la solution.
Ce qui nous importe, c'est comment faire
pour ouvrir les portes du paradis.
Faut-il passer par l’enfer ?
Entre crime et châtiment,
entre cris et chuchotements.
Que faisons-nous de nos sentiments ?
Ah ! C’est vous qui voyez.
Oui, c’est nous qui voyons.
Car...
C’est vous qui voyez,
c’est nous qui voyons.
Car même la personne la plus gentille
est un petit peu voyou. Que
c’est dur d’être clairvoyant lorsque
le monde est si trouble
que presque tout ce qui s’y trouve possède
une double, triple, quadruple posture.
Il y a trop d’imposteurs dans nos posters
qui nous vendent
des formules toutes faites, all-in,
tous frais payés par nos peurs.
Parfois, l’emballage est trompeur,
ça cache l’embarras de nos erreurs
et il n’est pas rare que la perception
de nos échecs nous tue.
Mais la beauté se situe
dans la perfection.
D’ailleurs, derrière chaque
génie se cache un cinglé.
On est tous des singuliers au pluriel,
dépendants du sablier qui s’égrène.
Solitaires dans l’ensemble,
en errance entre ciel et terre.
Nos racines sont des ailes.
Et pourtant,
nous sommes coincés
entre nos coutumes et le moderne.
On se demande quel costume faut-il mettre
pour enfin être nous-mêmes.
Alors peut-être faut-il tuer nos modèles.
Mais où nous mènent toutes
ces questions sur l’âme humaine ?
J’ai questionné le ciel
et je n’ai vu que des étincelles.
Je me suis accroché à elles
pour devenir un peu poussière d’étoiles,
un peu beaucoup poussière de toi.
De toi.
De toi, de toi, de toi, de toi, de toi,
de vous, de nous, poussière de nous.
Qu'on puisse être fiers de nous.
Qu’on puisse être unis comme une puissante
galaxie all-inclusive.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)